Rostrum
conference it's an honor to be here in
Edinburgh with you all today
my name is Carl Mcdaid and I'm a young
member from blanter and vice chair of
Scottish strong labor
conference Scottish and all of Britain
needs the labor government as a young
person I know that we can build a
brighter future for the Next Generation
young people are hopeful for the future
of Scotland in the UK but we know that
we need a labor government and Edinburgh
and London tip out the brighter future
that we all need
this weekend Anna Sarah and Jackie
Bailey have laid out a bold vision of
our favor and green of Scotland
Scottish labor is on the side of change
because it is on the side of the
Scottish people Scottish labor is on
your side
thank you labor can build the Tories out
of government at Westminster and put the
SMP out of Hollywood
only labor can unite our country
oil labor can clean up our politics and
build a Britain that worked for all and
in nearly a decade and a half of Tory
failure
only labor can build the Scotland that
works for all and to do that we need to
put kyoshama into number 10.
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen soccer
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you conference it is absolutely
fantastic to see you all here and the
energy embars about this conference is
phenomenal and thank you cara for that
brilliant introduction
and I have to say for making the rest of
us feel so old Cara is only 18 years old
Isn't that fantastic Carl well done
and Conference as you may have seen I
came here via Ukraine uh which wasn't
the quickest journey I have to say
um but it wasn't important visit
um and a humbling visit to have the
opportunity to meet president zielinski
in Kiev and say directly to him and the
Ukrainian people that should there be a
change of government next year the
support for Ukraine will remain the same
but also to go into the outskirts of
Kiev and meet some of the communities
that were hardest hit in the early days
of the conflict to see the damage to see
the atrocities but to see them get up
every day go to work mend whatever is
broken and show through their own
resilience that they will not be broken
by Russia I found that resilience and
that courage really really humbling and
we stand with Ukraine today and we stand
with them forever until they defeat
Russia
and Conference in that Spirit can I
thank you for the solidarity you've
shown this weekend towards the victims
of the terrible earthquakes in turkey
and Syria I can only imagine we can all
only imagine what those families are
going through and I speak I know for all
of us when I say our thoughts are with
them but the support that you've
provided to people here in Edinburgh and
communities across the United Kingdom
that is the best of our movement so
thank you so much for that
and us
thank you again for your leadership your
energy you and everybody in this room
have given labor back its confidence
here in Scotland
and
conference Alice and I have something in
common
and it's not our football team
it's the fact that when we took on our
leadership roles
people said the same thing to both of us
good luck
but you're never going to do it
well conference let me tell you
I know that together we can prove them
wrong thank you anas
well what a difference a year makes
four chancellors
three prime ministers two Ferris still
missing
and one rock star endorsement
that's right conference Rod Stewart is
voting labor
with we're finally reaching out to the
Scots who grew up on the Mean Streets of
North London
but conference seriously it's been a
long hard road to this point but this is
a new era for Scotland and for Britain
The Tide is turning on the Taurus and
the SMP
now Alice's right to thank the first
Minister for her service and I will do
the same
to lead Scotland for almost a decade
it's a political achievement that must
be acknowledged
and one thing we need to be clear about
wherever you stand on the Constitutional
issue we must respect those beliefs as a
sincere desire to make the future better
for Scotland
the first Minister was sincere about
that and it shaped her service to this
nation
and yes it shaped her political success
a success grounded let's be brutally
honest in persuading people who used to
vote labor to support her cause
conference we've got to reach out to
those people now
there will be people in all of your
communities
looking again at the future of Scotland
with fresh eyes
and we have to meet their gaze with
confidence
show them not just what the tour is and
the SMP have done to this nation
but the Scotland that labor can build a
fair or Greener more Dynamic Scotland in
a fairer Greener more Dynamic labor
Britain
but conference mark my words
we won't change any hearts or Minds by
sitting back and watching the battle for
power within the SNP
or by assuming that any weakening of
faith in their case automatically
benefits us
we have to go out there and earn it
prove we can understand the real
concerns of the Scottish people
that we've listened to the reasons those
voters lost faith in labor and Britain
and that we now offer the solutions that
Scotland needs
it's not about top it's not about change
at the top of other political parties
it's about the changes we've made to our
own
and the changes that we can now deliver
for the Scottish people
and that's the value of the steps we've
already taken together
I don't underestimate them
change with a purpose
to make our labor party fit to serve our
country that's why we had to show our
support for NATO is non-negotiable
understand the importance of sound money
anti-Semitism out by its roots country
first party second
foreign
that's the foundation that we've laid
together
as John Smith said
the chance to serve is all we seek
the job now is to set out what that
means for Scotland and Britain
and I feel that for too long we've been
stuck in a brace position buffeted from
crisis to crisis
I mean look around the country now
look around Scotland
families pensioners working people
people who've always kept their heads
above water
going without decent food or Heating
that's no way to live
and it's no way to run a country
people want decisive leadership once a
bold reforming government want change
that's a credible response to the
challenges that they face
because amidst all the chaos of the Tory
and SMP rule
there is a growing impatience for change
for National renewal
working people are tired of an economy
that only works for those at the top
they want public services that can
provide security and they springboard
for opportunity
and they despair of broken politics
which can't provide to their Community
with the tools to control their destiny
this is the change that Scotland needs
that Britain needs
and as in 1945 when we built a land fit
for Heroes out of the rubble of the
second World War in 1964 when we
harnessed the white heat of technology
to pay our way in a changing World in
1997 when we modernized the country held
back by crumbling public services and
outdated institutions labor must rise to
the moment and provide it again
foreign
[Applause]
that's the scale of our challenge
but we have to find a new way a
different way
chart a fresh course towards a better
future
now we could talk all weekend about
Labor's history in this nation
or about Scotland's success in the UK
it's leadership on renewable energy
it's vital contribution to British
security it's cultural Brilliance and
spirit of innovation all achieved within
this Union
all achieved by the solidarity hope and
idealism of working people
but conference let's face facts
many Scots
like Cara
don't remember a time before devolution
let alone our achievements in the last
century
we can't run on our history
we can only run on the change we offer
Scotland now
that goes for the Union as well
I don't believe in our Union just
because of our history
I believe in it because of our future
look at the great challenges we face
cost of living crisis climate change
standing up to Putin they're common
across our Nations
and sticking up a border doesn't solve
any of them
but
we must accept
that for many Scots they look at Tory
Britain and conclude the way out is the
way forward
and Conference that's the argument we
have to take on now
that's why today
I want to address those who've given up
on labor directly
and yes those who'd given up on Britain
I know the people of Scotland want
change and Hope
not a showy grandiose hope I don't mean
that
no what I mean is the basic ordinary
hope that we used to take for granted
the sort of hope you can build your
future around
that aspirations are made of that was
shared by working people across our four
nations in good times and in bad
the hope that people in Scotland are
once again looking to see if labor can
offer
now I go back to my childhood on this
I grew up working class in the 1970s
I know what the cost of living crisis
feels like
the anxiety and
yeah the shame
of not being able to pay bills which
only months ago were affordable
our phone was cut off like this and by
the way that was it then there were no
mobile phones once it was cut off it was
gone
but although we had our ups and downs
the one thing my parents never doubted
was that things would get better
that there was always that deeper hope
invested in US
in our future
in Britain that felt
secure
stable
dependable
it's more than a British value
it's what we tell our children
work hard and you can achieve anything
work hard and you'll get a fair chance
in Britain
and look
my parents didn't just believe this
it comforted them
but is it still true
I don't think so
I think many Scots have stopped
believing absolutely
that's the deeper cost of Tory Britain
a growing sense hard work isn't rewarded
that the bombs which tie us together
Community to community across our four
nations
have been allowed to unravel
so our children won't be better off than
us
conference this is what drives me I
don't want anyone in Britain to feel
like this about their future
now
that's not just words for me it's the
Story of My Life
the journey that I've been on
but it's also the story of our Union
because the case for the union rests has
always rested on the solidarity of
working people pushing Britain forward
in search of that ordinary hope
but when families worry like this about
their children's future
when hard work no longer guarantees Fair
reward
or even
that your contribution is respected
then yes that case becomes harder to
make
conference that's what we're fighting
for in our country
we need to meet the forces of division
with renewed hope every day
and not just in Scotland
I want to be prime minister for the UK
not just prime minister of the UK and
that's why I've always said
the path to labor Victory must run
through Scotland
[Applause]
so we need to raise our sights create a
collective sense of mission across our
home Nations
it's the only way to get that sense of
hope of possibility of solidarity back
but we can't delude ourselves
change must be credible that working
people have had enough of false promises
to last their lifetime
but that means politics have ordinary
hope will be hard
because of the damage the Tories have
done to Britain
hard because of the damage the s p have
done to Scotland
hard because of the damage they've both
done deliberately to the prospects of
our future together
let me start with the Tories
what'd you forget
the pain they've inflicted to our
economy and public services
to our reputation around the world to
our NHS and public services it's immense
they're not capable of the change that
Britain needs
and as for the cynicism of what they'll
do at the general election
to try and claim political credit for
the sacrifices working people are making
now
it beg us belief
but conference
whoever ends up in charge of the SMP
it's not as if they can give the Tories
any lectures on political responsibility
over 15 years in power and what do they
have to show for it
honestly
it's always somebody else's fault
and the reason is simple
they're not truly invested in Scotland's
success
anything Scotland achieves within the UK
is met with gritted teeth
seen as a roadblock to the one true goal
and so they do nothing
that's why standards in education are
going backwards why the tragedy of
Scottish drug debt hasn't been gripped
why they haven't just accepted Tory cuts
to local services but piled on the
misery
if it's not about the Constitution
they're not interested and Conference we
can never work with that so whatever
happens in the coming months my message
is the same No Deal under any
circumstances
foreign
[Applause]
the phony offers of support can end now
the blame game can end now
the unspoken political bond between the
SMP and the Tories the shared investment
in division that ends now
the change Scotland needs is coming a
labor government is coming
but the conference
those Scots who lost faith in Britain
they have a point about Westminster
Britain has an economy that Hoards
potential
and a politics which Hoards power and
these two problems feed off each other
no similar country puts so much decision
making in the hands of so few people
and that leads to Greater inequality
across our country than anywhere else in
Europe it's no coincidence
I'm utterly convinced about this
economic reform and political change
must go hand in hand
I come into politics late in my life
I've run large organizations
institutions that had to serve our
country
and I've changed them all including the
labor party
that's why I came into politics eight
years ago
a new way to serve a new way to get
things done more opportunities to change
our country for the better
but as a system without reform
Westminster can't deliver on that
pick any of the current problems in
Britain energy security productivity the
NHS honestly we could be here all day
but it wouldn't matter
the pattern is always the same
distracted by short-term obsessions
held back by a cynicism which uses low
trust in politics as an excuse to narrow
our ambitions we lurch
from crisis to crisis
always reacting always behind the curve
a sticking plaster never a cure
that's why every crisis hits Britain
harder than our competitors
the only country in the G7 still poorer
than before the pandemic
the worst decade for growth in two
centuries Millions on waiting lists and
Rising
that hasn't happened elsewhere
it's sticking plaster politics
and the harm it does to the prospect of
bringing Britain together
to renewing The Hope Scotland can move
forward in Britain
is vast
so we've got to take it on
only labor can fix this
only labor can unlock the pride and
purpose of all our communities
bring us together raise our sights
nurture a real sense of collective
Mission and drive us forward
to the fairer Greener more Dynamic
country I know that we can be
Britain needs a labor government for any
of this to happen
we all know that
and my message to the people across
Scotland who want to see that kind of
change is trust in US
there will be a clear choice at the next
general election
between more Decline and division with
the Tories
or a credible change with labor
change for Britain that brings with it
changed for Scotland and your community
but I also want you to know
my labor party understands that this
means we have to be in it for the Long
Haul
that the change on the ballot in 2024
must last must give people more power
resources to Scotland wherever and
whoever is in power in Westminster
that's the change Scotland needs now
and to be honest we don't just need more
Devolution in Scotland
we need it right across the United
Kingdom
the argument is simple
the decisions which create wealth in our
communities should be taken by people
with skin in the game
a huge power shift out of Westminster
can transform our economy our politics
and our democracy
unreasonable
to think our economy should give working
people a fair chance to succeed
it's not unreasonable to expect
Westminster to recognize the desire for
communities to stand on their own feet
quite the opposite
it's the change Scotland and Britain
need
change which comes from Unlocking The
Pride and purpose of communities
everywhere which spreads power and
opportunity out of Westminster
puts people in control an end sticking
plaster politics
a new approach to politics and democracy
everywhere in Britain built on a new
approach to growth and our economy
because comforts
you can't overstate the importance of
economic growth
it's the oxygen for our ambitions
the lifeblood of a strong society and a
dynamic economy
but again
this will be hard
every policy we announce must be fully
costed
the lesson of the last year is Stark
lose control of the economy and its
businesses and working people who pick
up the bill we can't let that happen
even when it puts a break on things we
might like to do in power
sound money in our public finances must
come first
but alongside it
we must be bold on reform on
reconstruction on National renewal
that's what people expect from a labor
government and we will deliver it
we will give working people growth from
the Grassroots
communities standing on their own feet
jobs that are well paid and secure we'll
end the Tory era of low pay with our new
deal for working people partner with
business on a modern industrial strategy
that will drive Innovation raise
investment harness the power of new
technology and put it to the service of
working people
and look
we will also seek to reset relations
with the European Union
we will look to increase trade reduce
friction
fix the brexit deal
that
that's a key part of raising our
Ambitions on economic growth
as is tackling climate change head-on
now I come to this
not just as leader of the UK labor party
but also as a dad
as a dad
I'm spurred on by the voices of our
children
The Cry of indignation demanding Our
Generation act before it's too late
it's a matter of Justice about the
fairness and better society that I came
into politics to create
but it's also the biggest opportunity
we've had in decades to make this
country work for working people
conference this is why we need a
collective sense of mission of national
renewal across our four nations
we've got to come together
write a new chapter in our national
story about how our generation built a
fairer Greener more Dynamic Britain by
tackling the climate emergency and using
it to create the jobs the industries the
opportunities of the future
that's what our green Prosperity plan is
all about
it's about turning the UK into a green
growth superpower
investing in Wind solar nuclear hydrogen
green steel and carbon capture
insulation for 19 million homes
and GB energy a new company that will
take advantage of the opportunities of
clean British power and turn them into
good secure well-paid jobs and yes
conference
yes pumpkin
because it's right for jobs because it
will help us to tackle climate change GB
energy will be publicly owned
and let's be crystal clear about the
benefits which flow to the Scottish
people from this plan
let's show how Scottish businesses and
families will get cheaper bills forever
how Scotland can get real energy
independence from tyrants like Putin
forever
and how we can give every Community from
Highlands to lowlands Islands to the
central belt a fair shot at the jobs and
prosperity of the future
it won't be easy we know that
but on planning on fossil fuel power on
challenges to the grid
we not only see the battles ahead we'll
run towards them
because there's nothing that wreaks more
of decline than the idea that Britain
can no longer build things that benefit
working people
it's exactly that kind of inertia our
opponents in Scotland relish
I will never accept that
but let's be clear about this as well
you can't fix our economy
without also fixing our NHS
you know
one of the great privileges of being
born in Britain certainly throughout all
my life
is the knowledge that if you get ill
if you have a serious accident
you'll get decent Health Care
whatever your circumstances
not every country has that
and the anxiety it causes is huge
but when you've got millions on waiting
lists and Rising
when you got to fight tooth and nail to
get a GP appointment
when you call an ambulance and it takes
an age to get there
isn't that precisely where we are
conference
let me spell this out
whether it's the SMP in charge or the
Tories we can't let sticking plaster
politics destroy our NHS I won't stand
for that and labor won't stand for that
make no mistake about who can deliver
for the NHS now and in the future
you can look at our past
you can look at our present
but most of all
you can look at the smp's record and a
new leader can't hide from this
it's the story of their time in power
writ large
no reform
no change excuse after excuse
the answer on the NHS is labor the
answer to change in Scotland is labor
and the answer to getting our hope our
pride our future back in Scotland and in
Britain is labor
thank you
so conference
reach out to your communities
reach out to people who are looking at
politics with a fresh pair of eyes
uncertain about what the future holds
for Scotland
and let us speak to them with one voice
let's say we know that Scotland needs
change
we know our economy needs to work better
for working people
that our Public Services need to be
fixed that climate change needs bold
action and that our political system
needs a total overhaul with communities
finally in the driving seat
none of this could be achieved through
more division
but if you place your faith in labor
this is the change we offer to you
to Scotland and Britain
the case for a New Britain the case for
change
a country where working people succeed
aspiration is rewarded Public Services
raise you up communities control their
own destination climate change is
defeated politics is a force for Unity
and for good a Scotland that is proud
confident ambitious and successful
thriving in a fairer Greener more
Dynamic Britain
a Britain where all our great Nations
rekindled the Shared Hope that can as it
has in the past drive us towards a
better future
that's the change we need that's the
chance we have thank you so much
conference
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
conference uh what a great speech to
finish with
um can I now invite Scott Arthur Vice
chair of the SEC to the Rostrum to give
a vote of thanks